Speaker 1: I got an email yesterday from Slug
about the topic of the left needing better
arguments when it comes to the topic of abortion.
In other words, the left needs to be better
prepared and better articulate the. Absurdity of
the right wing position on abortion rights and
the obvious logic of the left wing position
on abortion rights in the United States. And
Slug pointed out in this email to me, which
was really great, thoughtful email, that one of
the main topics of discussion in the abortion
rights debate in the United States, at least,
between just people who engage in the
topic. When does life begin? Is this
major topic of discussion? Is it a person or
not? Exactly. When does life begin? What about
personhood? And then we say, I would I would
argue accurately so. Well, if it's a person
five weeks after conception, then should there
be child support for that person at five weeks
after conception? Should there be citizenship even
if it if the fetus is the child of an undocumented
immigrant, if it's a person at five weeks, then
maybe there should be citizenship. And if so,
that means you can't deport a pregnant woman
regardless of her immigration status because
she has a real person in the womb. So, you know,
there's all these conversations and it's fine.
But Slug argues that it's a waste of time in
the sense that at the end of the day, it really
is a philosophical question and in a sense, a
religious question or a philosophical question
informed by religion. The anti-choice right isn't
going to accept arguments from doctors anyway.
Imagine that. Imagine that doctors could say,
Hey, you know what? It's a person. After 27 weeks.
The right's not going to accept that anyway. So
maybe it's sort of a futile effort to debate that.
And at the end of the day, we don't make
law on philosophical or religious beliefs,
or at least we shouldn't, although we know that
fundamentally Christianity is at the core of much
of antiabortion sentiment in the United States.
Fine. So slugs idea is the right says abortion is
murder. So the state can legislate around abortion
on the basis that it's like murder. But really,
we should be saying, no, no, no, abortion is more
like Oregon or tissue donation. This is the idea.
And in fact, before the fetus
is viable outside the womb,
it's really a lot like organ and tissue donation
in terms of our legal framework around it.
We don't force people ever to give away in Oregon
or to donate blood or to donate plasma or plasma,
as Trump used to call it, or bone marrow. We don't
do that even in some cases, and there are many of
them where someone needs blood or bone marrow
or an organ to survive. Right. There's a life
on the line. We never legislate that. You have
to do this thing. You have to donate bone marrow
or whatever the case may be. And in fact, people
regularly require those donations to survive. And
many people don't get them and they die. People
die on waiting lists all the time. That's tragic,
but we don't force anyone to go under the
knife and donate a kidney or get hooked up to,
you know, it's not an IV. You still have to get
hooked up to have blood or plasma or whatever
taken. And we never charge people who don't do
those things with murder nor manslaughter. It's
never even part of the conversation. You've
got to register as an organ donor to even
be contacted. Corpses can't even be harvested
for anything without written permission. Right.
If forcing organ or tissue or blood donation
is considered too invasive for anyone to ever
talk about doing it by law. How is forcing a
woman to lend her uterus for a fetus to develop
acceptable since it's even more of an invasion
of privacy and a violation of bodily autonomy
than donating blood or plasma or a kidney. The
fetus uses the mother's body for nine months. It
causes permanent changes. It risks health issues.
It potentially you can even die through pregnancy.
Not to mention, obviously, the responsibility
being placed on the mother for 18 plus years,
25 plus years, 35 plus years. Some of some other
millennials will understand. So the idea here is
from Slug, maybe the left should stop arguing
about when life begins and start forcing
the Anti-Choicers to admit they think the fetus
deserves more rights than everyone else and women
deserve less bodily autonomy than everyone else.
It's still sort of an in process idea that a
viewer sent to me. I wanted to share it with you.
Send me your thoughts as to whether you think this
might be a better angle or a useful angle. And
again, remember, it's not so much about convincing
the anti-choice right wingers. It's about framing
the argument in terms that aren't subject to just
philosophy. I mean, we don't force organ donation.
We just don't. And lives do depend on it. We don't
force tissue donation, blood donation, whatever.
And lives do depend on it. If we don't do that,
the invasion of forcing a woman to carry a
pregnancy to term is far more significant.
And so how do we justify that? It doesn't
seem to make any sense. Let me know what you
think. We'll do a follow up. You can find me on
Twitter at David Pakman. And I want to mention
again and we are seeing what's happening with
our mailing list. This is out of this world.
On Monday, I mentioned that on Memorial Day,
we're going to do a one day membership special.
We're going to blow out memberships to finish out
may. We may run out of memberships, quite frankly,
at a major discount. We're doing it on a holiday
because my lawyer would never allow me to do this
on a business day. He would say, No, no, no, no,
no, don't. This is too, too cheap. Our accountant
would say, David, this is terrible. Business
manager would say It's too big of a discount.
So I'm doing this on a federal holiday while
they're all sleeping and not paying attention.
Monday, Memorial Day. Get on our mailing list
at David Pakman dot com. You'll get an email
telling you here's the discount code. It's
good today only become a member and you'll
get all the perks that come with membership. The
bonus show, of course, which Alex Jones hates.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: He's furious about it. The commercial
free audio feed of the show, the commercial free
video feed of the show, priority access during
viewer townhalls, the next of which I'll be
announcing soon. So all you have to do today
is get on the mailing list at David Pakman dot
com and then you'll hear from us on Memorial Day